they marched in single file carrying
their injured comrades on stretchers
through the ruined steel works that have
been their fortress where for 82 days
they fought their heroic struggle
at least 260 are now in russian hands
the first driven away in buses marked
with a zed the hated symbol of russia's
invasion their final fate and that of
those left in the steel works still
isn't certain
julia tarasenko's husband alexander
isn't out yet but she's hoping he will
be soon
last time we spoke julia you were very
upset you were crying and very worried
about your husband
what are your feelings now this evening
yeah
i am waiting for him waiting for him so
much i hope that their remaining time in
captivity won't be much longer i hope
they will be exchanged soon i hope that
very much i really am waiting
the battle for azov style is now over
the ukrainians say there was no chance
of lifting its siege with military means
its defenders held off thousands of
russians who had massively overwhelming
fire power the invaders unable to prise
them from the sprawling network of
tunnels below
the ukrainians say the men bought time
and held down thousands of russian
troops
unfortunately it's impossible to unblock
these people in a military way and
there's no other way to rescue them
other than the method we've been using
this was the only way
but the russians say this is a surrender
and among the fighters are some of their
most hated enemies who they say are
nazis natalia zaritska's husband bogdan
is in the garrison
she says she's worried what the russians
may do to the men
i have no list of people and i have
no information
but
at the bottom of my heart i feel that he
is okay i don't lose my hope
the ukrainians say the fighters will be
exchanged for russian prisoners some
remain inside as of style for now but
their commander says the fighting is
over
it is a victory for russia but at
enormous cost it has control now the
city reduced to rubble emptied of people
while its forces continue to struggle to
take any more territory
dominic waghorn sky news hakeef